cet homme est le pire prédateur de l'
histoire de la musique populaire j'ai un don
ils veulent juste le faire tomber et
tuer son image le
problème de robert ce
sont les jeunes filles
honte à vous r kelly
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] il
y avait la folie avec aaliyah
[Musique] il
y avait un certificat de mariage qui
disait qu'il l'avait épousée quand elle avait 18 ans
et il avait 27 ans sauf qu'elle avait 15 ans et c'était
dans tous les  la presse autour du
premier album qu'il avait écrit et
produit pour elle qu'il appelait l'âge
n'est rien d'autre qu'un chiffre
contact sexuel avec qui essaie de se suicider
après que cela se termine
trois ans plus tard, c'était en 1991.
[Musique]
ce n'était pas un secret en novembre 2000,
il y avait des chuchotements dans la
communauté musicale de chicago les
communautés noires et noires  des
côtés sud et ouest que kelly fréquentait souvent les
lycées et le rock and roll
mcdonald's et le centre commercial evergreen plaza
j'étais sous l'influence de la marijuana
et de l'alcool et je l'ai fait
il a ensuite eu des rapports sexuels avec
moi
même si je ne l'ai pas fait  avoir la capacité
de consentir
quand il a fini kelly m'a dit tu
ne vas pas me plaire
un quart de milliard de dollars de revenus
pour lui-même il avait de l'
argent il était une vache à lait
ils n'allaient pas empêcher la génération de revenus
[Applaudissements]
six ans ont été assez longs nous
ne voulons plus de retards nous voulons qu'il soit poursuivi
maintenant
[Applaudissements  ]
j'aime quand je ne peux pas savoir qu'il ne l'a pas
fait je sais que ce n'est pas lui ils veulent juste
le faire tomber et tuer son image nous le
voulons en prison il y a une cassette de lui
urinant et ayant des relations sexuelles avec une jeune
fille
[Musique]
oui il a été acquitté mais les jurés qui ont
vu cette vidéo ont été horrifiés c'est la
chose la plus dégoûtante et la plus horrible que j'aie
jamais vue de ma vie un nouvel album
sort ouais ce qu'on appelle des culottes noires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je  Je ne peux pas me sortir de l'esprit ce que j'ai vu
et ce qui s'est passé Je veux envoyer des
allumettes à
quiconque croit qu'elle a été victime de nos
victimes de Kelly ne devrait pas avoir honte
48 femmes ne peuvent pas mentir
euh les femmes à qui j'ai parlé  pendant 19
ans de reportages à travers le pays
séparés par des décennies racontant la même
histoire qui ne se sont jamais rencontrés
ne peuvent pas tous mentir
[Music]
so [
Music]
so
[Music]
cet homme est le pire prédateur de l'
histoire du populaire  la musique
une forme d'art avec une longue et ignoble
histoire d'hommes maltraitant les femmes
[Applaudissements]
j'étais une jeune fille de 17 ans marchant
dans le centre commercial
qui voulait juste être quelqu'un
malheureusement j'ai été la proie de mr
kelly et son entreprise de
guérison est  possible je suis fort je l'ai vécu
j'ai survécu et maintenant je demande justice